The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Museum of Holography.
Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of November first, nineteen ninety-eight.
My guest this week is holographic artist Melissa Crenshaw, who will be celebrating twenty years of working with the Splendid Light in nineteen ninety-nine.
Melissa currently has an exhibit of her work, both past and present, at the gallery located in Artisan Square on Bowen Island, British Columbia.
The gallery is open Friday, Saturday, and Sunday, and the show runs through November twenty second.
Melissa Crenshaw Trivia.
Most holography publications mention Canadian artist Melissa Crenshaw.
But did you know she was born in Kansas?
Here's the Holotalk interview with Melissa.
It runs about twenty minutes.
I will not be back on after the interview, so I will thank you now for tuning in.
And hope that you will continue to tune in to all of the guests that I have coming on the second season of HoloTalk.
Here's Melissa.
You've been involved in so many things.
You've been involved with holographic production, curating, lecturing, writing, and education.
Why don't we just go down that list and talk about some of those things in order?
Okay.
As far as your production, I think some of the listeners might be interested in your work with multiple color reflection holography.
I guess I started to explore the possibilities of color back in the early eighties.
Um I've almost always worked in reflection mode.
It's only been this last year that I've started to work in transmission.
Wha why reflection other than uh white light transmission or one of the others?
Well in the early days, like I didn't really like the rainbow effect.
Mhm.
It just didn't work with the kinds of images that I was producing.
The images that I I was producing needed to basically maintain their color from any viewing position.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Yeah.
And with the rainbow technique of course, you know, as you change your vertical parallax or your vertical position the the the y you know, the image shifts colors.
So that works beautifully for some people's work, but for mine it didn't it there was no reason for that to happen.
So I started to work in reflection mode and in the early days I just tried experiments using um variations in exposure um to shift colors slightly and then I started working with the um the triethanolamine technique swelling technique which I had to teach myself.
And um That's rough isn't it's awful.
Oh yeah, mini blue streaks.
There's a lot of holograms that could have gone into addition that ended up going into the trash because there was a a one inch by eighth inch blue streak on the left side down by the bottom.
I mean it it's it's almost painful that that technique, but it was the only way to do color.
It it is the only way to do color unless you have three lasers and blah blah blah.
So I just did it.
And the early work I was doing then was I was really excited about the Russian constructivist work um from the early part of the century and there was a lot of that work being exhibited and I was actually um exploring uh geometric shapes and the same kind of spatial relationships that the that the constructivists were actually looking at and you know, color reflection holography was a great way to do that.
Did you work directly uh with the reflection hologram itself or did you shoot masters first and then do transfers?
No, in the in in the beginning back in the early eighties I did a lot of I did a lot of single beam reflection work.
I mean it was the optically it was the simplest technique you could do.
And I put all of the complication, if you like, in t into the color technique.
There's only a few of us that have actually worked with that very simple optical technique and it's too bad because there's a type of image and there are things you can do with a single beam reflection hologram that you really can't do with a multiple beam.
Mm-hmm.
So I did that for a few years and then I started working multiple beam but still not using a master.
And then in the mid eighties I started working with masters.
How did you ever manage did you come up with a special technique that you could let the listeners know about?
Because I know a lot of people like to try this triethanoline.
Okay.
You can't go through holography without giving that a shot.
How did you come about where you got it down to the fact that you knew that you weren't going to get any streaking on the plate?
Okay.
But it's it's very much trial and error and to get your own individual technique.
In terms of the shooting geometry and the pre-swelling, um the best paper is probably still the the very early paper by Lawn Moore and Steve Grew.
From the nineteen eighty two International Symposium papers from Lake Forest.
Um, that explains it.
Steve McGrew then produced a paper showing a graphical method whereby you could actually um lay the optics out on graph paper and know how to do your angle changes and things, which are critical for color control.
That's an excellent paper to explain that.
And the rest of it is just trial and error.
I mean, I basically soaked the plate in triethanolamine and I would squeegee the surface of it very carefully, wash the back of the glass, let the thing dry for three hours, shoot it and see what happened.
Yeah.
Color mixing's very tricky but you can um you know you just keep experimenting.
It's it's uh it's an R G B color mixing process, so um very similar to a monitor on a computer.
I guess so, yeah.
That is that RGB yes of course yeah.
It's it's light.
It's it's light mixing, it's additive color.
Mm-hmm.
And then later on toward the mid to late eighties you were working with Sydney Dinsmore.
Oh yes, yes.
I Sydney came to me in actually in in nineteen eighty six I in eighty five and eighty six both I worked in China.
I worked in Beijing and in eighty six I was um directing a very large e international exhibition there and I needed an assistant curator and I hired Sid.
We didn't even know each other at that point and we ended up sitting in this little tiny room in China together for six weeks and came out of it best friends and she asked me then to do a collaborative project with her.
And that project ended up lasting seven years.
And we did we ended up collaborating um until she moved to Hong Kong.
She moved to Hong Kong to get married and have a family.
So that was a wonderful uh collaboration and we produced figurative works.
Um she had some kind of a council grants.
We were able to go to Germany and um work with Fred Untister and shoot pulse masters and we also worked with Hans Bierkelgate in Chicago shooting pulse masters.
And he generated a number of series and we were very successful with that work.
We actually made a real living with that work.
As far as your curating, you've also curated a number of different shows over the years.
Mm-hmm.
Here in in North America and Canada and also in Europe I imagine and China itself, didn't you?
Um, mainly the two that were in China and then in Canada, um I actually Sydney is was a c was a curator also and I assisted her on a couple of shows, in particular Images in Time and Space, where I was sort of the lighting specialist for that very large exhibition.
Um I directed the exhibitions in Beijing, two of them, a small one and then one in association with an international conference in eighty six.
And then I did the big um nineteen eighty eight Lake Forest International Symposium exhibition in in Chicago.
That was a really big show.
It was really fun.
Were you involved with the publication Wavefront?
Oh yes.
Um I I did just photography for that that journal for a few years and then the last issue which we rec we called the recession special was actually produced by Al Razudis and myself.
And it was a bit of a spoof.
Um everything was so dreadful then with the museum closing and the the the the market and art crashing we decided we needed to do something to liven people's spirits up so we produced a bit of a spoof issue and that was really quite quite fun.
How many issues total for Wavefront?
Oh boy, I don't even know.
Um maybe there were ten or something.
Okay, I believe that was mostly Bern Simpson and Al Razudis that did the did the work on Wavefront.
But it did come out of Vancouver.
Beautiful publication.
Pardon me?
A beautiful publication.
Oh it was a wonderful journal.
I think it was you know, it it had a real artist slant.
Um, it was very non commercial and um of course, you know, everybody's pockets got emptied doing it.
But it would it would be wonderful to start that up again, uh, especially on on the internet.
Which is quite possible, you know, 'cause I was real involved now in um HTML language and stuff.
So I don't believe there are any publications on holography anymore, are there?
The only one I know of is the holography business news that in Lancaster Started.
That still comes out.
That's pretty much aimed at the embossing industry though, but there is no you know, w but at one time we had three journals and we don't have the kind of comprehensive holosphere um or wave front journal now that covers the whole industry, which is a real shame.
What about your lecturing?
Um, I haven't done any of that in a while, but I was very fortunate in that because I did a lot of the early color work and holography, people wanted to know about it and I was, um brought in to lecture at various places.
I I did workshops and lectures again in Beijing.
That was the Institute for Post and Telecommunications.
Mhm.
Um I lectured in MIT once, I lectured at the University of Mississippi, I've done various lectures for galleries and museums.
And that's that's always kind of fun.
You know, you get free plane tickets.
Do you still do that?
Travel rents?
Um not too much.
Um, the last couple of years I've been working uh for an engineering company here that develops photonic switches.
I I bought a house, I needed to kind of, you know, concentrate on er you know, earning a living for a while.
The last big conference and lecture I did was the Nottingham conference in England two years ago.
Mhm.
The um I think it was I think that's called the International Conference on Art Holography.
Yes.
And and there's actually a site on the web for that as well.
Yeah.
What is it like making your first hologram?
Why even get involved with that and how did you get involved with it?
Um that goes back to what, seventy eight, seventy nine?
Seventy nine, yeah.
I was a social worker in the seventies.
I lived in Chicago.
I did a lot of um I worked for HUD agencies.
I did a lot of street social work, emergency services and I took a year off because I got very burnt out.
Yeah.
And I thought, well I'll just study film or something, right, for fun.
And then I found out about holography.
I had been reading about Carl Pribram's um theory on the holographic uh mine.
Mm, yes.
Stanford neurosurgeon.
He was a he was a neurophysiologist, I think.
Yes.
And had some very fascinating um papers on using the hologram as a model for understanding how the n neural networks and things operate.
Mm-hmm.
And so I thought, well that's really neat and then I found out that there was actually a place in Chicago that taught and displayed real holograms.
So I went there and I immediately signed up for class.
That was Lauren Billing's place.
Um Chicago Museum of holography.
Do you remember who was teaching back then there?
John Hoffman.
Okay.
And it was an amazing time because in my class I had Doug Tyler, Ed Leslie and Steve Smith.
No kidding.
Wow.
And Tom Speckovich and Ed Dietrich had just graduated with the class before mine.
So it was a real hot bit of holography at that time.
It was wonderful.
Um taught really good basic techniques.
So a lot of people got a good foundation there.
And how did it feel when you saw your first hologram?
Oh I thought it was incredible.
I couldn't believe it.
I did a little tiny two inch by two inch laser transmission image of a a ribbon curl.
Uh it was a sand table and the the the curled ribbon went back about twenty inches.
Oh, no kidding.
Wow.
Yeah, and it was a little late and you had to use a laser to see it.
I guess I was hooked at that point.
Why not?
I love laser transmission holograms.
I love them.
Yeah, they're amazing.
I think d talk about data storage, uh I mean I I've got some pulse masters that um were shot.
Um there's one that Michael Page shot for me for a commercial job and you can see the entire inside of the room where we shot the master.
Wow.
It's just incredible.
You can see the clock on the wall like fifteen feet away.
Like it's just unbelievable.
Do you have you ever had a holographic portrait done of yourself?
Well, not well, not really.
I I model for some of the holograms that Sid and I did.
We believe it turns modeling.
So they're not really of me.
Yeah, I I'm in more like a formal sitting, like this is Melissa Crenshaw that someone a hundred, two hundred years in the future can look back at.
Um well, yeah, I guess so.
I mean the work I just I just installed a show here on the island where I live and there are actually two images of me that it's quite obvious that it is of me.
Mhm.
Um, they're not portraits of Melissa, they're they have other titles.
Um I'm just a person in in there but yeah, definitely somebody could look at that someday and go, and that was the artist.
When she was real young.
Yeah.
I would I would like to see it happen where um most of the people who were involved with the field of philography have portraits done for future generations to look back on.
Yeah, it would have made a lot of sense, huh?
You know.
Yeah.
You're involved with education now at a physics department.
Well, sort of.
What I really am is I'm c I'm called a physics research associate and it was a wonderful opportunity.
I had to close my studio in Kit Solano.
Um I had to find a new place for it.
And Byrne Simpson, who's been a involved in holography for a long, long time, arranged for me to move my entire optical system into the physics department at Cap College and they brought me in as a as a research associate.
So I don't actually teach, although the lab's available for demonstrations if we need it.
But mainly I just have the opportunity to go there whenever I want and work on um the kind of research we're working on now is to hook up the computer animation and video system, you know, through the L C D screen and to do holographic uh transfers of that kind of information.
So You're doing some work with your older Pulse Masters from the eighties as well.
I am.
Yes, I just this show that I just opened, uh has three new well, there's about ten new images but I've got three on display.
And I did a few experimental masters when Sid and I shot the Pulse Masters for our work and I'm using those now, which is kind of neat.
And I'm doing just open a acromat um open aperture acromat transfers which are real neat.
They make a black and white image right close to the film plane.
Mhm.
And then of course as you move off the film plane the whole thing just explodes into spectral color.
Wow.
It's sort of a breaking the rules technique.
Why don't you let the listeners know about the show when it opens, how long it's running, where it's located in case anyone from your area happens to log on and they're listening to this.
Yeah, it's just a small show.
I live on an island.
I live on Bowen Island, which is just twenty minutes from the mainland where Vancouver, British Columbia is.
I live near a huge city, but this is a wonderful little island.
It's a a lot of artists live here.
And we have a local gallery called the just the gallery at Artisan Square.
And that shows open Fridays, Saturdays and Sundays, uh through November twenty second.
Mm-hmm.
And I've got some of Sid's work and mine and I've got some early abstract pieces.
I've got some of the Z axis pedestal abstract pieces from the early eighties and then I've got three of the new pieces.
For school age children who may be listening right now, we get a lot of educators and students that come onto the site and listen.
What tips would you give them or advice if they would want to get involved with holography and especially did you're a woman working in the field, what would you say to some of the female student listeners about getting involved with science and technology and art and technology.
What have some of your experiences been in the past ha has things changed for you and what do you see happening in the future with it?
Well, I think one of the beautiful things about holography is that it opens a door for basically m rather non technical people, which I would have considered myself before I did holography.
Mm-hmm.
It opens the door to artistic people, it opens the door to sort of non mathematical people.
It opens the door into a world that is used to just be the domain of of physics essentially and science.
And that's a really wonderful thing.
It holography provides a bridge between the creative world of image making and you know, the the the world of physics and science.
And to be able to cross that bridge and go back and forth between those two worlds is a a really wonderful thing to be able to do.
Mm.
And I think that it's interesting that uh when I was um, you know, younger, like twenty years ago, there weren't a lot of women still going into science and physics.
And yet this interesting thing happened in holography, which is that I would almost stick my neck out and say that the majority of art and d art holographers were women.
Mhm.
Somehow it was like here was an opportunity for women to get involved in in an imaging that involved technology and they just jumped at the chance and became excellent.
I mean some of the best holographers in the world are women.
Mhm.
So go for it.
My backup career like house painting My daughter has a physics professor who I found out was a student that I had a young lady that I had in one of my holography classes.
Oh wow back in the early eighties.
And she found it so fascinating that she just kept reading books about it and then decided to uh study physic physics, yeah.
Wow, that's fantastic.
That's really great.
I mean any anything that opens a a door for you, you know, a and the more doors you have open for you the more interesting your life is going to be and holography just you know, it covers so many different areas.
It's really great that way.
Now you've you had your own lab.
You didn't rent facilities, right?
No, I never had to.
I I've always been extremely lucky about labs.
Mhm.
Did you work with the sand table system or did you have the Oh yes, I worked with everything.
Um I started out at at this school in Chicago and we were able to rent for a dollar an hour channel labs on the weekends, which I did.
Then I went I moved to Seattle and I I I had a b a bachelor of science degree at that point and I wanted to get my my Bachelor of Arts, so I went to a small state college called Evergreen State College, which just happened to have a a fabulous holography lab that no one ever used.
They had a fifty milliwatt he helium neon laser, they had an NRC optics table.
I just couldn't believe it.
Just sitting there.
Huh?
Just sitting there waiting for me.
So I went to school there and got my my bachelor of arts and then I ended up teaching holography there for a year.
And I basically had that place to myself.
And then Global Images wanted to set up a lab in Vancouver and have an artisan residence program so they hired me to design the lab and design the optics and to sort of run that program.
And I did, and when I came here to do my four month artisan residence, I never left.
And uh Walter Clark owned Global Images and he ended up going to New York and then I believe London to run his embossing business and I ended up owning the lab.
Wow.
I know, it was just amazing.
So then the next thing that happened was that I thought I was going to have to close the lab and mothball all the equipment and everything and then all of a sudden Bern Simpson came up to me and said, How would you like to move it to Calp College?
So I've been really lucky that way.
Just really lucky.
I've always had equipment.
So you're basically working on uh not necessarily a newport table but one of the production tables now, I would imagine right?
Well the it there's my old facility I had a um a a homemade table if you like it with a seven thousand pound concrete and steel number.
But when we moved into Calp College, Holocrafts a very successful dichromate company here donated a five by ten foot um NRC table.
Wow.
So yeah, so I mean I've just been really lucky that way.
Let me ask you this.
You've worked on both systems or a number of different systems.
I'm speaking s specifically of tables.
Mm-hmm.
Sand tables, you've got that concrete and steel table that you just mentioned and the new port.
If the homemade I'll call them homemade for lack of a better term, table is well constructed.
Do you really notice that much of a difference in the end result?
Absolutely not.
There you go, folks.
My table, my optics table we built for a thousand dollars at the lab and it worked like a charm.
It was beautiful.
And I must honestly say that I cannot I can't tell uh the the table I'm working on now, if I w had to go out and buy it new it would cost about twenty five thousand dollars.
I can't possibly even imagine in a million years that there's that much of a difference between the two.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, you just learn.
I mean, I've built everything.
I mean I've built all my optical holders, my components, my frame holders and everything.
Very little off the shelf ever ends up in my lab because of money.
Mm-hmm.
But that's okay, you know.
Well Melissa, do you have any closing comments or remarks you'd like to uh say before we close out the show?
I don't know.
Hello to everybody.
Um maybe just that, you know, I think a lot of us uh had a bit a bit of a rough time there when the museum closed and when the publications went under and people stopped collecting, but it's great to know that people are still doing the work and um you know, it's it's a wonderful field and it should continue.
Amateur and hobbyist philography is still fairly strong.
Oh, yes, I think so.
You know.
And that's great.
Which is nice started.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Well Melissa, thank you very much for being on the show.
Okay, well thank you very much.
And don't forget to tune in sometime during the week.
This will go up on Sunday night, around midnight, and then it will be up for a week.
Okay.
Well Melissa, nice talk.